foreign
expert shares the seven toxic signs of
highly insecure people and how to deal
with them and this article is grade a
dog crap you asked me to tell you what I
thought that's what I think is that good
I think you've been fairly clear yeah I
don't think there's a lot of ambiguity
here
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
show about mental health about
relationships about your marriage about
your kids whatever's going on in your
life we're here to walk alongside you
here's the goal of the show
I want to help you have a better
marriage I want to help you have
um better relationships do better at
work when you'd help get get some common
sense like some new insights into your
mental health because the the language
around mental health in this country is
insane it's just Madness and so my goal
here is to give you some no-nonsense
like so everybody can understand it and
give you some practical tools and tips
on how to go make your life better and
um so I'm so grateful that you've given
us your most precious resource which is
your time thank you so much for being
with us if you want to be on this show
give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask ask and you can fill out the form
there and uh we got a fun show today we
got an article that I can't wait to get
to it because it gave me hemorrhoids
just reading it like
like Beyond Preparation H hemorrhoids
like maybe need to go see somebody
hemorrhoids um and I what I would
imagine is one of the most uncomfortable
uh doctor visits a person can go to
let's go to Donna in Lexington let's
just move on from here Donna what's up
hi wow I am talking to John deloney no
way I'm talking to Donna this is
incredible how's it going
great great excellent excellent what's
happening
well my question is how do I have a
fulfilling passionate marriage when both
me and my husband have different
attachment Styles oh no are you an
attachment style person
unfortunately
jeez attachment style people I here's my
my picture in my head there's attachment
style people and uh
Enneagram people and they put on those
medieval clothes and they fight like in
the public park with wooden sticks
that's what I imagine in my head LARPing
yes
well I don't even know that there's a
word for that so congratulations so
you're an attachment style person
um okay so tell me more about it is one
of you anxious and one avoidant or one
of you secure and one of you anxious or
or you've got different attachment
Styles and it's all coming down
well we've been having symptoms of sort
of communication mishaps for the years
that we've been married uh and one day I
decided hey there's got to be something
to it and I took a quiz online to solve
all my life's problems yes the online
quiz
yes uh and found that I was anxious
attachments so I sent it to my husband
and he was avoidant
and that explained a lot of things in
our marriage and it really helped us to
communicate better
but it hasn't really solved
um
I guess
my issues and his issues which are
I guess I get this empty feeling when
I'm not getting connection right and so
I go and I chase for it and then when I
chase he
hides runs and it's very
difficult yes you'll end up in the dance
right
um that so many couples end up in it's
just the dance one's chasing one's
hiding and it just works like on an
infinity loop and then you find each
other and you connect and it's gonna be
this way forever and it's awesome so hey
um I was poking fun at you at the
beginning
um John Bowlby is is a famous British
psychologist he he came up with this
idea of
um attachment theories attachment ideas
and there are some great uh validity to
them I I I actually think that they've
got they're good to know good
understanding and the great Mary
Ainsworth took those and expanded on
them they're good stuff
what I don't like about them the same is
I don't care for the Enneagram the same
as I don't care for most
um not what I would call mental health
Diagnostics like if you've got severe
mental health disorders or some or
personality disorders they can be very
helpful but just run-of-the-mill I've
got depression I got anxiety the reason
I don't like them
um especially things like Myers-Briggs
they they become well that's just who
this guy is
I'm of this guy and she's this gal and
so you know
and so I think they can be good for
reflective tools an online quiz like oh
I I fall into this bucket
but none of that matters when it comes
to looking at the person across from you
and saying
what do you need how can I love you
better today
regardless of quote unquote how it makes
me feel
now of course this can be taken to an
extreme you know someone's like I need
sex four times every day right that's
insane right or I need you to quit your
job it can get it can get way out of
bounds and so I'm I'm asking everybody
listening to be reasonable here but
um
I my wife and I have very similar dance
that you and your husband have okay
which is I am anxiously avoidant I'm a I
have a terror um I'm fearful of
rejection and when I come on like I've
got a I come in hot I got a uh a lot of
energy and her body says get out of here
Hide And it and then it sets all my
alarms off which then in turn sets her
alarms off and we have one big anxious
house right and then we try to solve it
through
our various you know addiction ways we
cover up things right so um what I'd
love to do is actually just just for to
placate me
um
where's your where does your anxious
attachment come from do you have
somebody leave you in childhood was was
connection weaponized as a child
definitely
um
[Music]
dads okay Dad not in my life uh First
Love was pretty much uh my teenage First
Love Was a Serial cheater and physically
abusive
um
so yeah had a little rough go of it
growing up but I think as much as I like
to say I'm over a lot of things I can
see the symptoms of what and I don't
like to uh be the victim in this
situation I don't like to think like
that but I do recognize the symptoms of
ways that
uh those things have affected me and my
relationships as an adult so I want to
give you some peace I want to give you
some peace because you said thinking
these type of anxious anxiety responses
are at the nervous system level
and so you can think through no no I've
got a good one now
like this guy's the good guy he's he's
the one he's not one of my stepdads he's
not going to leave you can think that
cognitively and you probably did because
you wouldn't have married him but your
body put a GPS pin and Men Who are
supposed to keep you safe or men who say
the words I love you or men who say the
words I care about you and to put a GPS
pin in them and said watch out
they're gonna leave they're gonna hit
you they're gonna cheat on you're gonna
destroy you and so there we hear the
fight or flight all the time but there's
fight flight or freeze and then there's
another one that's that's I don't say
it's rare but we just don't talk about
it very much it's fight fight or fawn
I'm gonna get so nuzzled up and close to
you I'm going to be overly intimate
overly connected that'll keep me safe
surely you won't he hit me or cheat on
me if I'm if I'm really really close to
you right and of course that can be
insane but it but it can work too right
so
you're what's happening to you is at the
nervous system level and I want to honor
that
and probably uh where's your husband's
um he's not here to speak for himself
but where does his route from have y'all
talked about that
well he's wonderful and his family is
wonderful but uh very controlling
environment growing up but very sweet
people uh
other than the controlling aspect so I
think
I love a good anxious avoidant person
like they hit me but they do it gently
and it doesn't always hurt right wait
you're trying to make sure all the
relationships are fine they're fine
because they don't want them to leave
right
um so maybe they are sweet and they were
hyper controlling and when people are
hyper controlling usually that means
they're the performance of the people
they're in relationship is going to
determine how uh how much love there is
to go around or not
and it's easier for him or they're just
hyper hyper critical critical critical
why are you wearing that why are you
doing oh my gosh why are you fixing your
hair like that did you brush your teeth
did you and then that body checks out
he's probably pretty talented at being
um completely alone in a crowded room
huh
very much so yeah you nailed it there
yeah he can he can go inside of himself
is what I say so again let's throw let's
throw attachment Styles off okay we got
that figured out you you your body tells
you when you get anxious we got to get
really close and his body tells him when
he's anxious we gotta get far away
okay so the goal here is not to fight
attachment it this uh attachment Styles
the goal here isn't to
um
make each body feel unsafe all the time
it's actually the opposite the goal here
is to teach our body the thing that kept
us safe When We Were Young is what's
destroying our relationships in the
present
and so we have to teach our body that we
weren't safe then but we are safe now
and that just it's a skill so he's not
broken you're not broken your bodies are
doing exactly what they should they're
trying to protect you they've seen this
before when you come in and you're like
oh honey honey and you're all anxious in
a super attached probably you're asking
him why he's wearing that belt and why
are you wearing those socks with that
shirt that doesn't even and he's like
and he just disappears and you and
here's what's crazy people with anxious
attachment they know when the person
leaves even though they're in the middle
of a conversation you can feel them
evaporate in front of you they just they
just go away but they're still talking
they're still engaged with you and you
know it and it makes you bananas and how
I know because that's me Donna we're the
same all right so here's what you have
to um both of you have to know
your anxiety
that you are trying to solve by nuzzling
by getting close to him by taking
dominion over him is what I'll say
trying to control him
that anxiety is getting stronger every
time you give in to it
so this anxious attachment is going to
get Tighter and Tighter and Tighter over
the course of your marriage until one of
you just leaves
and I don't want to cast a shadow over
you guys or and when I say leaves that
could be literally they leave or they
just disappear in onto the couch behind
a six-pack right the other side of it is
he's got to understand that being not
being in true connection with somebody
will kill him physiologically his body
will die because his body knows you we
are all we got brother
just it's just us and us
and it will it will you've read the the
you've heard me talk all the time about
the the data on loneliness okay so
here's what both of you have to decide
to do
you have to decide we're going to enter
into a period of time and it could be a
short period of time a long period of
time then there's going to be some
crisis in your marriage some one of your
parents is going to get sick one of your
kids is going to say something's gonna
happen and your body's going to want to
drag you back to what it knows and
you're gonna have to be really
intentional there
but here's how we're gonna we're gonna
move forward the first thing is we are
going to
consciously when our bodies start to
feel anxious we're gonna stop take a
huge deep breath as deep as we can we're
gonna drop our shoulders let it out and
ask ourselves what are you trying to
protect me from here
what do you try why don't I feel safe
right now oh because he just walked into
the other room okay
he still loves me he's still here we
gotta check ourselves every time
and this will be tedious this will be a
beating and he's gonna have to decide
every time he starts to unplug nope I'm
staying present I'm staying present what
I found is I was
too much for my wife and what she found
is she wasn't enough
and we had to meet somewhere in the
middle and now there's a safety
mechanism that she feels she now knows
when I'm about to pull away she actually
will lean in further and I know when I'm
about to lean in more I actually Retreat
and that's from I'm trying to meet her
need she's trying to meet my needs so
that I can meet her needs so that she
can meet my needs and it just stays on
this incredibly beautiful Loop does that
make sense
it does it does it sounds like a
long way to go to get there but I'm
really hopeful that we can do it yeah I
a hundred percent you can
um and
I think let's let's stop the attachment
language and let's start with
my body tells me I'm not safe when you
pull away and you're gonna know what
those pull away things are write them
down write them down and talk to them be
open about them when you do this when
you do this when you do this my wife has
told me when you stomp when you when I
come into the house I just walk really
heavy when I walk into the house boom in
my uh living room is suspended over the
garage and so it it just moves through
the house
it just sends her body it just she's
like I gotta get out of here and when I
see her like make eye contact with me
and bolt I don't know why my body's like
she's gone forever she's not she's not
and so we I we've had to sit down and
say
here's the things that make me feel
unsafe
and so when I come in not always but
often she'll stop and come give me a hug
when I wake up in the morning she'll
stop and give me a hug not because
that's what she wants to be doing
she's got a whole list of things she'd
rather be doing but because ah now I can
I can draw my shoulders and vice versa
so all that to say is I want you guys to
stop using attachment language start
being very clear about hey this action
you do makes me feel unsafe will you
lean in this way
this action makes me feel unsafe will
you lean in this way and if there's a
time when you start to feel
um
your body starts to feel anxious his
body starts to feel anxious
have uh give each other permission to
say my body is telling me that
I'm beginning to feel unsafe and
make that a part of your conversation in
your home and what you're going to find
at first is you're going to take it
personally like I feel awful that I'm
making you feel nobody's making us feel
anything it's just our body's trying to
protect us but that's how we're gonna
have to talk about it we have to bring
it to the light we have to say I don't
feel safe right now or my body's telling
me that you're walking away let's start
that language about how can I feel more
safe
and that's the path forward you may need
to get a book like one of these little
I gotta come up with a cool name for
this but a journal that you write these
things down or you take care of yourself
body's trying to keep you safe
that's it she's doing his job now it
needs to learn a new way to keep you
safe which is in connection direct
connection and neither of you are using
the other one to meet your uh anxiety to
to quell the anxiety
you're with each other
fully intertwined
the same field
thank you so much for the call Donna
we'll be right back
[Music]
I've got a word from our sponsor
betterhelp listen I've been on both ends
of therapy in my life I've gotten it
myself and I've walked people through it
and I've seen the benefits from both
sides when someone owns their past and
the cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we are back
um it's time for everybody's favorite
segment facts are your friends let's do
it
I'm not gonna comment on how terrible
this music is I'm not gonna say a word
about it
I plowed through Kelly I got this
a psychology expert shares the seven
toxic signs of highly insecure people
and how to deal with them and this
article is grade a dog crap alright so
uh here we go a psychology expert this
is gonna be great
hey
that word gives me hemorrhoids now all
right so March 1st 2023 it came out
says working with difficult
personalities can dampen our ability to
think clearly and make sound decisions
that's how this article starts working
with difficult personalities can dampen
our ability to think clearly and make
sound decisions I reject this premise
wholeheartedly
no one can control my ability to think
or make sound judgments unless number
one they break me like I think uh it's
the purpose of hell week with with Navy
Seals they want to like no sleep
constant physical exercise constant
people screaming yelling at you they
want to push you past a point where you
are have any ability to think they've
taken that from you you sign up for it
but they take it from you and then they
want to see who you are on the back side
of that right so someone can break you
or number two you give it to them
you give it to them
that's it
I work with I've worked with difficult
people my whole career and when I find
myself unable to think clearly or make
sound decisions it's because I've got
caught up in their drama I have handed
them keys to my life I've become like
Dawson's Creek character like oh what's
happening now it's all on me it's on me
I reject this premise that other people
can control my life that way now let's
keep going
um then the person tells how great they
are and how smart they are and blah blah
through my research I found that
insecure people are often the most
difficult to deal with agreed insecure
people are very tough to be in
relationship with and I will also say
that most of the time that insecurity
comes if I'm their boss because I'm not
being clear at all or if I work for them
I have created an anxious life so much
so that I owe so much money in student
loans I
um am so desperate to meet my own
insecure ego needs with a job title or a
salary number
um I've created a work I have to live in
this city and if I don't live in this
city it's ridiculous and all my dreams
is
so I have to I'm in I'm in servitude to
this boss so either I'm a boss working
with these folks and I'm not clear and
so they get this insecurity or
I'm insecure because I'm working for or
I'm working for an insecure boss but I
don't have another option I've boxed
myself into a corner
um and I I live in these this soap opera
but I'll agree I'll agree working with
Instagram people is very tough whether
you're their boss or they're your boss
right
insecure types are extremely risk-averse
and unproductive some can be downright
nasty or display abusive behaviors
then they should be fired
if somebody is abusive in the workplace
or they are downright nasties this
article says
you shouldn't have a seven step strategy
for dealing with them they should be
fired they shouldn't work there anymore
because they're destructive
psychologically emotionally you're gonna
make less money with your business
because you have these kind of morons
running around
um and the whole culture is going to go
to hell it's just it's ridiculous or I'm
not gonna work for you
and I have left
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars on the table and walked out the
door
on a couple of different a couple of
different times throughout my career
because I'm not going to work with an
insecure boss who is always using me to
fill in gaps in their soul I'm not gonna
do it
I'm not gonna do it I I
it's not worth it over the Long Haul I'm
not gonna give you a stroke I'm not
going to give you my heart attack I'm
not going to give those things to you
I'll let my I'll give those to my kids
and my wife I'm not gonna give those
away all right so um they say the most
common toxic behaviors he says the most
common toxic behaviors are overly
concerned about what others think of
them never express affirm opinion suffer
from chronic inability to make decisions
even when choices have little
consequence they frequently try to
change the direction of projects or
meetings they put other people down to
make themselves look more important they
constantly talk about how busy they are
when they actually aren't
um to show that they're in demand
they're paranoid meddlers who make who
question your every move
let's let's distill some of this down
um
we are so caught up in in I'm talking to
my own psychological Community now we're
so caught up in our fancy little labels
let's say what this is
this is somebody who's abusive somebody
who's a liar
and somebody who is displaying highly
narcissistic traits
so let's don't say like is somebody with
um insecure attachment but no this is a
jerk it's a Jerk It's a person who's not
telling the truth who is using other
human beings as punching bags to make
themselves feel tough
and when it's power differentials in a
workplace it's even worse because that
person sometimes is trapped right so it
goes on how to handle insecure people
as little as possible I don't handle
people
I just don't like that language
um it it acts like we are all Hannibal
Lecter like we're all playing our own
little marionette God game where it's
like I'm handling this person I'm
handling this person I I you've been
like I've found out that I was getting
handled like Hey we're gonna have a
meeting to figure out who's gonna tell
John this thing uh dude it made me
insane just come tell me and if I'm a
person who can't hear that I should be
fired I shouldn't work here and if
you're a person who can't tell me you
shouldn't I don't you know you should so
all I have to say is this
how to handle p take that out
either you're with people or you aren't
with people okay let that be a a way to
operate now there's certain things I
don't say around certain people there
are certain like um I'm just not gonna
have that conversation I'm not gonna
talk theology with that person I'm not
gonna talk psychology this person it's
just it's just not I'm not going to talk
about covert with this person it's just
so if you want to call that handling
fine but I just think that's being wise
um but here we go how to handle insecure
people
and again this article is called a
cyclics ugh
a psychology expert shares the seven
toxic signs of highly insecure people
and how to deal with them and this so
far this article's worth
um if you fold it in half it will be
worth two ply all right so the first
step is how to activate your detective
mindset
you know what you shouldn't ever do
activate your detective mindset
Sherlock Holmes turning turn interacting
with insecure people into a learning
opportunity oh gosh all right some of
these I agree with actually I agree with
them I'm gonna be honest where I can be
honest and some of them I think they're
insane number one assess the size of the
problem yes
are all these interactions bad or is
this person just kind of annoying over
here fine let's move on with your days
this person one of those people that
always has to claim credit no matter
what fine I I'm not gonna lose a second
of sleep over that if they're dishonest
and they're stealing my ideas and
they're putting them forward and they're
getting paid for that whatever that's a
different conversation but again I'm
just gonna go handle that directly I'm
just gonna go talk to them directly
um so assess the size of the problem is
this a huge deal or a little deal that's
good
number two identify the root causes of
the problem no the world does not need
any more pseudo-psychologists we got too
many people
using Google to diagnose each other and
to try to solve clinical issues in the
workplace stop stop
I don't even try to do this I don't I I
don't have any interest in like wonder
if this person's got anxiety right this
person's really rude and I'm gonna close
the door and say hey you can't it's not
okay for you to talk to me that way and
at this hour we're going to communicate
then let me know because I need to make
some decisions then not like oh well I
wonder what's the root cause I'm not
gonna do that
number three cultivate genuine
compassion yes all of us always
that that person who's insecure is
somebody's kid
at one time they were a little kid
and whatever series of things happened
to them over the course of their life
has led them here is there an excuse no
is it a context absolutely be
compassionate be compassionate
um over invest in one-on-ones no it's
over and it's reinforcing now every
single leader and supervisor should have
a one-on-one meeting every week with
their staff maybe every two weeks at the
most with their direct reports there's
gotta be that human connection there and
unfortunately it can't be done over
email I don't think I have not seen it
successful
um you gotta get in a room and meet you
gotta go grab coffee together those
things are all good but the idea that
this person is a little more insecure so
I've got to over invest there
number one times finite number two your
team will quickly know that you're
favoring this person number three that
person's Behavior becomes rewarded
psychologically it becomes a reinforcing
context for oh if I act like this I get
more time with supervisor I get more
relational needs right
number five have an exciting outcome in
mind I'm not even gonna dignify that
with a response
um that gives me diarrhea on top of the
hemorrhoids number six be transparent in
how you communicate yes
it says it goes on to say and this is
true insecure people have a tendency to
see gaps in arguments yes absolutely
punch holes at everything yes because it
gives them a a an opportunity to not
make a decision cool clear clear
I am certain about this is what I
believe I'm very clear there is no there
is no ambiguity here this is the way and
most of us don't like that most of us
don't like to to speak like that we
don't like to lead like that we just say
things like hey man be cool I don't even
know what that means hey man uh like
this we start at 10 30. I don't know you
know if you are late again you will be
fired
that's clear
and I see Kelly pointing at me right now
that hurts my feelings Kelly that makes
me insecure
um number seven fill in the gaps
together
um yeah that's I mean
there's a
they shouldn't just be for Instagram
people should be for everybody everybody
in the organization should have a sense
of ownership from the person sweeping
the floors to the person
um uh purchasing things to the person
selling things to the CEO everybody's
got ownership in this how this thing
works and everybody plays a part in the
person who's getting served on the back
end of this thing
um number eight working in increments
that's scaffolding I can see that being
positive
um especially at the beginning of
projects absolutely number nine show
that you are not a threat no
cause I might be
if you continue to not show insecure
issues if you're not insecure now but if
you lie if you bully other people if you
constantly distract a meeting and and
make us where we can't get our work done
you're not going to work here very long
or I'm not gonna work for you very long
I'm gonna seek to create a world where I
can exit this as soon as possible
because this this this rubs off on my
family life this rubs off on my personal
life this rubs off on my psychology and
my physiology it rubs off on everything
I'm not going to do it I'm not going to
subject myself to that just so I can
have some fancy job title or I can have
some dollar amount it's not gonna do it
I'm not and I implore you out there
listening don't don't put up with this
so
um show that you're not a threat no I'm
not I I might be a threat I might ask
you to not work here anymore if if you
work for me or I guess it's not
threatening I might just leave right
um this says pay compliments and Express
gratitude I admire what you do and I'm
excited to continue learning from you no
don't do that it just reinforces the
behavior it just makes this insecure
monster stronger not doing it here's
that don't participate walk away
walk away
[Music]
I
asked me to tell you what I thought
that's what I think is that good
I think you've been fairly clear yeah I
don't think there's a lot of ambiguity
here
we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show Rocco
all right I'm back and my blood pressure
is coming back down let's go to any
here's the deal
you know what not even gonna say it
let's go to Brock in Raleigh North
Carolina what's up Brock
hey Dr John how are you today partying
dude what are you up to
oh nothing much just living the dream
when you when you figure out how to
teach that let me know because you're
gonna make a billion dollars
will do actually I'm running a scam here
at this podcast thing so it's pretty
awesome it's awesome so what's up dude
hey uh well first of all thank you so
much for taking my call
um I it means a lot yeah thank you for
calling man
well I I have some some things written
down so I don't ramble too much uh so
I'm just gonna read it to you if that's
all right let's do it let's do it
all right um I've always had a tendency
to uh take things very personally I've
always been a very sensitive person
uh for as long as I can remember I have
been afraid of people being angry with
me uh disliking me yelling at me not
wanting me around stuff like that
uh to put it simply I've I've always had
a very intense fear of getting in
trouble
and this causes me to have very low
self-esteem low self-confidence I feel
like I'm often annoying to people uh or
unreasonably weird uh
and I I tend to get very defensive uh
easily
this has been having an increasingly
negative impact in my personal and
professional life
how can I overcome this fear oh man
um that's I
I know this I know that was hard for you
to write down and it was especially hard
for you to say it out loud and um I'm
going to tell you I'm grateful for you
thank you for doing that okay that was
Brave okay
um
trying to think where to start
do you have any I mean you pull that
drawstring all the way to when you're a
little one
um
who is did you have people watching over
you like a hawk
uh I did yeah
um my my dad was
kind of well he was emotionally abusive
uh towards my mom and my my sister and
I've been told to me as well though I
don't remember anything and so my mom
was was very
um I think sometimes she she may have
overcompensated to make up for that
so your fear of stepping out of line one
millimeter your body's right it's not
lying to you
it's seen the consequence of getting out
of line
right
yeah and it's seeing the consequence of
getting out of line from somebody who
was supposed to look you in the eyes and
put their hands on both sides of your
face and tell you every single day of
your life God I'm the luckiest person in
the world that I get to be your mom or
dad
right
yeah
so
at the outset of this I want to applaud
your body for working properly
it knows what happens it's seen it
happen to a little kid and it will be
damned if it's gonna happen to an adult
and so you are on high high alert
tripwire alert
for any sort of way that either a you
have you're out of line
right you're a little bit off the center
or even more difficult and I would say
uh more maddening is your body's highly
tuned to other people thinking you might
be off
yeah because when you're a kid if you're
I'm just gonna make up something you're
pouring cereal and you're five and
you're learning how cereal works right
it all comes flying out of the out of
the bag out of the box you know and you
get two Cheerios on the counter
big whoop but if you grow up in certain
households somebody will get down close
to your face and say what kind of stupid
and disgusting can't even pour
cereal
and so you're not actually off center
but somebody else perceives you to be is
that is that ring true a little bit yeah
definitely it does okay
so I want you to at first at the
beginning here make peace with your body
it's doing its job
you got hit before it's not getting hit
again okay
the second thing is
is if this continues much longer it's
going to drive you mad it's gonna kill
you
and I don't say that metaphorically I
mean it's going to have issues with your
blood pressure it's going to have issues
with cognitive function it's gonna have
issues with sleeps gonna have issues
with making relationships fair enough
yeah definitely okay so you hear me say
this a lot on this show it's especially
applies to you
the things that kept you safe as a kid
are going to destroy your adult life and
so we just got to get a handle on them
okay and the thing we have to know about
anxiety is the more we avoid something
the stronger that anxiety response
becomes I mean because it means it's
winning it's doing its job it's like oh
and I do this he hides awesome I'm gonna
do this louder right and so you've been
doing it for so long now your boss sends
you that email at 3 30 on a Friday it's
like hey can you swing by my office boom
you're in full fight or flight because
you're getting fired and that freaking
boss can't believe am I right
yeah that yep 100 and that boss could
have just y'all could have just gone to
lunch and he told you how awesome you
are and giving you a raise and he's like
hey swing by at 3 30. can you come by
real quick doesn't matter it's Off to
the Races because every time it restarts
it restarts it restarts it restarts
um yeah
so here's what we have to do
oh man let's see here
I'm gonna use a word that I hate using
because it makes you it's gonna make you
feel like I'm being dismissive of you
and it's gonna instantly make you think
of like some fat guy with a beard
sitting crisscross applesauce on a cloud
okay
the path forward here for you is mindful
and I don't mean meditation although
that may help what I mean about mindful
is
is consciously catching your body when
it spins up on you
and asking yourself the question out
loud
what am I afraid of right now
okay what is my body trying to keep me
safe from
from him oh I'm good I'm good
what is my body trying to keep from her
yeah she is abusive I'm gonna stop being
in a relationship with her
see what I'm saying and what we're going
to try to do is create a gap between
we're going to spend the rest of our
lives trying to build a gap between that
stimulus our body gearing up for War and
what we actually do about it ah
I'm gonna take a deep breath drop my
shoulders
and I'm gonna consciously slow walk
through my boss's office
I'm gonna consciously do it even though
my body's like run get down there right
now I'm gonna consciously slow walk till
I get there
I'm gonna sit down and say how's it
going man I'm gonna feel my body the
whole time trying to get anxious on me
and keep telling myself this guy's safe
this guy's safe this guy's safe now can
I ask you a hard question
often people who grew up in a um
pressure cooker
create Secret Lives
and they become extraordinary performers
are there things in your life that if
they came to light
would be highly embarrassing
um or get you fired or or be something
that you would not want to explain
uh yeah I would say so okay
I would sit down with a counselor and go
right into those
okay because the other thing your body
knows is if you're carrying I call it an
anxious life but if you're carrying
secrets that if they got out it would be
over your body has a hyper invested
interest and nobody finding out about
the secret
if you owe a hundred thousand dollars in
student loans
and you have a boss that's calling you
into office on Thursday it knows if you
do get fired it's all she wrote it's
over
you're not gonna eat you're gonna lose
your house you're gonna lose your car
you're gonna you're gonna the
government's gonna garnish your wages
and your Social Security when you get
like all these things are gonna happen
right so if you don't owe anybody any
money
that Friday phone call or that Friday
email that you get you swing by like
okay
if he fires me that'll suck and I'll be
mad and I'll have my feelings hurt and I
sure like this job but
I'm not destitute you see the difference
there
yeah definitely and so
um
it's about creating a non-anxious life
and those things that if they came to
light
you gotta deal directly with those
because I'm gonna say they were
initially they're an outgrow an
outgrowth of that childhood but now
they're choices that you're making
is it fair
yeah yeah
how hard are they going to be to deal
with
uh I think
some of them are going to be
easier than others
um give me an example
oh boy uh
let me think
um no you just had two pop right into
your head and then you tried to Slough
them off pick one of those
uh I work from home two days a week and
um
I would say that it can be kind of hard
to focus when I'm at home working
so you know you log in and you don't do
anything
I I get what I need to done but I don't
do much past that yeah
uh are you one of those quiet quitters
uh well I'm not sure
don't
um okay so what else that's that's a
light one there's more
um
I would say that
okay well there there is a big one uh I
don't know
how comfortable I'd be sharing it okay
that's fine um
I had a uh I I just turned a manuscript
in for a new book and I had a chapter in
it called the biology of Secrets I ended
up pulling out I ended up cutting that
chapter but I need you to know
um
what you're carrying now will will
destroy you
okay so I want you to call somebody
today that you can sit down whether
that's a friend whether that's a mentor
or whether that's a professional
counselor
um
uh that you can sit down and say hey
I've I'm in over my head
will you commit to that
yeah definitely
think of your body's response in these
moments as just alarm systems trying to
keep you safe
I want you to keep a Notes app open on
your phone or get yourself a journal
something that you carry with you
something small something I don't care
what it is
but I want you to begin to write these
thoughts down when you get that email at
three o'clock and it's like oh crap what
did I do I want you to write that down
or the first thought is you think you
you think they found out write that
down and then say what did they find out
what did they find out
and if there's a couple of things that
would get you sent to jail or get you
fired you need to deal with that
directly quit it knock it off
or at least have the at least have the
uh
uh Integrity to quit to resign and go do
something else
yeah um
because that I'll just leave that there
but I want you to begin to challenge
these things what you're going to find
is most of them are not true
your feelings are strong and loud and
Powerful signals but they're not always
true in fact they they can be rarely
true
um and so I want you to acknowledge them
and feel them write them down look at it
demand evidence from these things you're
writing down and then move on
consciously walk into the middle of that
anxiety
um so let's think of an easy one
um
let's say you used to have a a
pornography addiction let's just
something that's common you used to have
a pornography addiction and you don't
you know anymore not even a thing like
don't look at it all
and you're married now and your wife
says hey I need to use your computer
real quick and you're instantly your
heart goes starts beating really fast
because you spent 10 years hiding
your computer or you spent 10 years
always clearing your search history and
then go in and clear the cache all that
stuff right I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna just
and so you're gonna write it down what
is my body scared of oh that's not me
anymore
or hey did you get the cereal out this
morning your wife asks you and your body
sets off into fight or flight because
when you were a kid that question could
get you uh a smack across the side of
your head
and now you're older and you're going to
write it down
this question sent me into Fireflight is
did I get the cereal out the answer is
yes and it's our house it's my house I
did I got the cereal out and she'll
probably go put it away ding dong or
okay
um see if there's enough for me to have
some like something simple right so
let's begin to write these things down
all we're doing is we're teaching our
body we used to not be safe
now we are and
like all things
especially with anxiety
easy to always be pointing your finger
out there out there out there
sometimes
we're doing things that our body's
trying to protect the world from
don't keep secrets
don't keep secrets kill you
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey last night
um Ben and I and some guys went to the
Underoath show like some
early 2000s screamo music back to his
rad that was dope but what I didn't know
until Ben was getting tossed around the
pit and he ripped his shirt off he has a
huge Britney Spears tattoo on his chest
which is amazing dude congratulations I
didn't know you were so tatted up
especially with Britney Spears and so
today's song of the day in honor of uh
Ben's tattoo
um I mean it had the hearts and
everything it was really it was well
done it was whoever did it was excellent
um surprising but excellent songs called
toxic and it goes like this baby can't
you see him calling a guy like you
should wear a warning it's dangerous I'm
falling There's No Escape I can't wait
who wrote this song
good God I need a hit baby give me it
give me it awesome you're dangerous I'm
loving it
too high can't come down losing my head
spinning around and round do you feel me
now no cause I don't know what you're
saying
with a taste of your lips I'm on a ride
you're toxic I'm slipping under
all right
Ben you're toxic is that I don't hey I
love you guys stay in school don't do
drugs bye
[Music]